we originally brought you the story of a
submersible called limiting factor it
was used to reach the deepest parts of
all five of the Earth's oceans we took
you along as it reached Challenger Deep
nearly seven miles below the surface of
the Western Pacific limiting factor is
the brain child of Adventure Victor
vascovo and he's been on board as it
reached those record depths he joins us
here in studio this morning Victor good
morning good morning first of all I'm
sorry for your loss I know you knew a
few of the folks who were on board I
also know you were reluctant to say much
about this until we knew what actually
happened
How concerned were you that something
was going to go wrong here and what do
you think it was that happened I was
widely discussed in the submersible
community that this design was so
unusual being a cylinder with different
materials it broke many conventions in
safety precautions to have
spherical pressure vessels made of metal
and so therefore there was a lot of
concern that there could be a potential
for failure over time and it's just very
unfortunate that's what we believe
happened that over repeated Dives which
it made that it eventually imploded
should Titan have been in the water
as an experimental vehicle we're always
trying to push the boundaries of
technology to make it more affordable
and more accessible for scientists but
in this case taking paying passengers to
the Titanic on a submersible that was
probably not fully tested was probably
unwise there are a lot of people that
are wondering why this is something that
people are doing for tourism it's also
used for research the submersibles that
are being used why do we need to go to
the depths of the ocean in this way well
the oceans constitute 70 percent of our
planet and of those Oceans 80 percent
are still on exported so half of the
world is still completely unexplored and
yet there's all these concerns about
climate change and how does the world
work we still don't understand many of
the mechanisms of our world and that can
only be ascertained by doing more Marine
research and it's chronically
underfunded so having people pay to go
to these places actually helps Marine
research so that feeds the ability to do
the research that you need to do to
explore absolutely
after you knew two of the men on board
what was it inside of them that pushed
them to try to reach the edges of the
world and what will you remember most
about them I think what pushes anyone
that goes deep into the ocean in order
to the tops of any mountains is a great
curiosity about the world and wanting to
experience it directly so pH nargiela a
French commander in the Navy he was very
passionate about the Titanic made over
30 Dives there and I think he wanted to
share that with so many people and then
my friend Hamish Harding who I went to
the bottom of the ocean with and into
space with was just someone that just
loved adventure and was again trying to
experience the world as much as he could
in one Lifetime and that's becoming more
possible for people as there's more
affluence in the world we will see more
of this people wanting to explore does
this give you pause about the next time
you might try to explore no not at all
because for 35 years there's never been
a fatality or even Serious injury using
submersibles to explore as long as they
abided by pretty Universal conventions
of how they should be built and operated
so we function for four years diving all
over the world in the deepest ocean
trenches with no major issues it can be
done and it can be done safely but it
needs to be done correctly and you
believe it can be done with with
tourists
I believe that yes with properly
classified and operated submersibles
absolutely I've had two heads of state
in My Submarine down at the very bottom
of the ocean or other places so it can
be done it just needs to be done like
many things in life like air travel or
mountain climbing it can be done safely
or it can be done in a way that's
actually not safe Victor thank you for
being here this morning again as Jeff
said we are sorry for your loss as well